from cnr.com there is a member of
Congress who as it turns out is a 911
truther and he's a Democrat and he's a
Democrat who illegally pulled a fire
alarm it's rep Bowman Bowman responds to
resurfaced 911 truther blog I regret
posting any any anything about any of
these people yo this is for Real New
York rep Jamal Bowman issued a statement
to The Daily Beast after the outlet
reported that Bowman promoted wild
conspiracy theories on his person Al
blog in a Monday report according to the
outlet Bowman's blog was operated during
the same time as a middle school
principal at the Cornerstone Academy for
Social Action in the Bronx as far back
as
2014 around February 2016 the blog was
scrubbed of all posts which ranged from
poetry to essays topics ranging from the
Florida recount to the Y2K bug that
stoked fear the century blah blah blah
the turn of the century and speculation
the 9911 Terror attacks were an inside
job by the US government the notion of
build the notion of building sens
collapse being control demolition which
was a large component of the inside job
theory has been denied by by Nest we
most of us know this quote 2001 planes
used as missiles targets Twin Towers
reads a stanza and an archived poem by
the New York representative per The
Daily Beast later in the day Building 7
also collapsed H multiple explosions
heard before and during the collaps H
allegedly two other planes the Pentagon
Pennsylvania hijacked by terrorist
minimal damage done minimal debris found
hm the poem
continues we blamed Obama oh we blamed
Osama sorry went to war in Iraq captured
Saddam Hussein killed him Bin Laden in
is AF is Afghan so he went to war there
too in the poem Bowman credits a 2005
documentary Loose Change and the 2007
documentary series Zeitgeist which
explore theories behind the terror
attacks that counter official narratives
okay he says I don't believe anything
these cranks have said and my life's
work has proven that blah blah blah nah
I'm sorry I got to tell you I don't know
a single person who has written about
9/11 truth seeing Loose Change 911 and
Zeitgeist and has changed their mind
yeah I I don't know a single person he
changed his mind once he got exposed
while being in Congress that's this is
why we archive everything because we
don't know who's going to run for office
and it's good to have the receipts but
then what if the conspiracy theory is
that Bowman's actually secretly based
and trying to uncover deep conspiracies
within the government oh God I remember
zist and then they had that section
tacked onto it with like methra and
stuff like that yeah the religion
section
and I think uh good documentary it was
fun I I I got to go with aam's Razer on
this one Bowman is a grifter he was
lying then because it earned him
internet points and he thought he would
get recognition he would get traffic or
whatever how old is how old would he
have been when he first would he he
would have been fairly young I think no
this is 2014 it said but he's not so old
now is he this is 2014 he's posting this
stuff yeah but how old was he then I
guess I guess yo it's kind of wild to
think that was 10 years ago so right now
he's 47 so he he so he was reasonably
young
37 bad poetry yeah 37 hey I'm 36 don't
call me old Tim no what I'm saying is
you're an adult you have a world viw you
have a perspective yeah you don't just
change your mind like what happened in
Bowman's mind where he was like at one
point saying what caused building having
a collapse it was never hit hit by a
plane then 10 years later to be like oh
he was like I'm going to have so many
Facebook followers after this we thought
about it enough to write like to make
art about it The Poetry doesn't
even is is there anywhere where I can
see this full poem because does it does
not appear to rhyme no the hums is his
best rhyming word maybe it was like
spoken word maybe he was preparing to
perform it somewhere the real the real
story uh he he invented slam poetry
right there's like an alternative
reality where Jamal Bowman has its own
blog and his own successful like Rumble
Channel and he's talking about 911 truth
stuff slam slam poetry was invented by a
dude obsessed with
Z you heard it here first ladies and
gentlemen he was 35 at the time that's
what daily B says he was 35 at the time
and he maintained an online Journal
Relentless dstr strongback
blogspot.com it gets better and better
I'm sorry I did not see this one on my
2024 bingo card that he's actually a 911
when he change his mind recently he
never did he's just lying right now
yeah's no way lying before or now or
possibly both which means he's a good
politician and a good Democrat yeah
there's no
like tomorrow a new poem comes out like
I was just
kidding he's not going to get punished
for this by the way no we we all know
this he can literally pull a fire alarm
to try to uh prevent a vote from taking
place and nothing happens that's crazy
hey look we got his blog here because we
went to the Wayback
machine and uh let's see we got December
18th 2014 poor Bowman look man I don't
care if you believe in Crazy
conspiracies I don't believe if you I
don't care if you believe in sane
conspiracies just give me your logic
I'll argue with you if I disagree but
what I don't respect is Bowman clearly
believing these things and then acting
like he doesn't yeah but that explains
him being a politician I guess he should
become our nation's Poet Laureate I
don't understand what's happening he
should be the next White House Press
Secretary but only speak in poems that's
sort of rhyme but also maybe not okay
hold on I propose we forgive Bowman for
pulling that fire alarm no jail time
expunged from his record if he comes out
and admits he does believe 911 was an
inside job and he performs his poem on
the floor Congress that performs this
poem here that's true okay I don't think
this is loading I think it's Jamal
Bowman's people are scrubbing it as fast
as possible no this is this is
archive.org it might be on archive. toay
as well archive.org is known to scrub
things for political reasons archive.
today archive not they're not as
reliable it's it's not as reliable it
may or may not I I tried archive today
yeah I I use it all the time although
for some reason I can't get it to load
on the laptop I'm using in the hotel the
hotel is like that's a risky website
don't go there yeah I know it just never
loads all right we got something love
the
world oh here we go it's loading
Bowman's Mick Loving it no it's gon it's
giving us this this this business
business again yeah okay he performs the
poem and then trash house signs him as
an artist and he starts rapping the poem
on May 201 poem called
recapitulate in which he talks about 911
truism planes use as missiles yeah it's
not just one he was he was thinking
about it he needs to do a rap with Ben
Shapiro dude come on you mean like that
would be the best crossover ever it
would explode the internet and destroy
it forever that'd be great especially it
was about 911 truth do you know anybody
who watched loose change or Zeitgeist
was a fan of the film in some capacity
and today has been like no I I think
it's all wrong I've never seen Loose
Change although I did watch zeitgeist
back in the day back you know when it
was first released and I thought it was
fun I thought it was entertaining and I
was like uh you know I'll keep an open
mind or something but I was never really
a truther dude I wonder I wonder if this
is retaliation for the fire alarm thing
cuz this is this is character
assassination with the jne of this guy
look what they wrote both Zeitgeist and
loose change were favorites of mass
shooter Jared Laughner who killed six
people and injured 13 more including
then Gabby gords in a rampage in tuon
Arizona in January 2011 the only reason
you include that which is like a
nonsense statement Zeitgeist and lose
change were seen by millions of people
the only reason you include that is
because you're trying to character
assassinate Bowman they must be like you
are being punished for doing this maybe
he's like Eric Adams getting raided by
the FBI about two frakin weeks after he
criticizes Biden's border policy maybe
it's the same maybe maybe they thought
that he was going to criticize the admin
the regime I don't know I can't see what
website wrong right now but Daily Beast
is the one who broke the article which I
would assume they oh it's like they
would they would be like good job with
that fire alarm that was that was
hilarious yeah maybe but some Bowman did
something because Daily Beast is
basically like deep State media yeah
that's why I I'm surprised that they are
going after him he must have there must
be a reason there's got to be some and
obviously it's not the fire I mean the
firearm they could care less about they
were having Bowman went to Pelosi and
was like I don't know if I can do this
anymore man Trump's just not that bad a
guy and they're like he's cracking we
got we got to shut him down prom you
promise me You' tell me the truth about
9/11 if I just
ran no how about he he finally completed
his mission breaking into the archives
and found all the records and the only
reason he ever ran was to try and get
access to previous information and they
found him out there's got there's got to
be something weird going on because The
Daily Beast especially would not
criticize well basically any Democrat
for such a thing they would hide it they
would cover it up look at this justify
it they'd be like oh well it's it's a
youthful indiscretion this is crazy they
said there can be no mistaking that
these are the subjects of Bowman's poem
he refers to Zeitgeist director Peter
Joseph by name shout out to John Perkins
William Cooper Michael Moore Peter
Joseph and Adam Curtis he wrote John
Perkins is the author of the book
secrets of an economic Hitman and
William Cooper was a radio host and hero
of the militia movement and of Oklahoma
City bomber Timothy McVey known for
fevered ramblings about aliens the
Illuminati and the supposed man-made
origin of HIV and AIDS Cooper died in a
sh with law enforcement in November 2001
Michael Moore and Adam Cur are both
left-wing documentary makers why are why
are they smearing Bowman in this way
bringing up the most extreme individuals
ever it's like it's like saying Bowman
was seen on video drinking water Hitler
also drank water that's what they're
doing maybe maybe after the fire alarm
incident maybe he's political dead
weight and they're worried about that so
they trying to force him out I was
thinking similar who wants his seat who
do they want to put in his position yes
to coordinate someone else for it they I
think I mean they the election he's
being he's up for re-election uh in
November this is is they just dumped
acid on his campaign Daily Beast said
you're out so something must have
happened where they went to him the look
political individuals don't play games
like this unless they have no choice the
first move by any anyone in any kind of
business is going to be can we convince
someone to do what we want them to do
easily you know when you before going to
war you try and get your your you know
the Rival country to do what you want
them to do peacefully because it saves
money time and energy you don't you know
save save money I have to imagine
someone went to Bowman and said we don't
want you to run we want you to retire
and he was like no I won't do it and
they were like do not run against us and
he was like I'm running and I'm going to
win and this is what happens well it's
sort of like what happened with Carrie
Lake there with the uh the head of the
head of the Arizona GOP openly telling
her hey and there's a bunch of people
that don't want you to run for office
wouldn't put it past the Democrats I
mean they're just as shady and there are
other Democrats who are I'm just looking
it up right now are Democrats who have
already announced to challenge him for
the primary so there he's not so one of
one of them is one of them is uh in on
the joke
presumptively one of them was a huge fan
of his poetry back in the day it it
could be simply that opposition research
found this and then gave it to the DA
beast and said have fun it's totally
possible but why would they even run
with it unless they had a problem with
Bowman because he's a Democrat yep
that's the point that's crazy this this
story gets crazy at first at first I'm
like this is just a funny story about
how Bowman's 911 truth are and now it's
just like there's conspiracy that we've
uncovered and the media is going to
write crazy right-wing conspiracy theory
that Bowman blah blah blah is being
sidelined or whatever yes dude there's
no reason for anyone to go after him
politically like this if they just said
we found his blog and it's kind of weird
but he said he apologized for it and
moved on I'd be like oh but to lump in
like Mass Shooters and and terrorists
and name drop them in the article with
him that's there crazy claims and I
found his blog and I'm like read the
where you find it I'll send you the link
but I there's no guarantee cuz it gave
me the same gear for it's um there are a
lot of people trying to access it right
now well maybe maybe that's probably but
yeah the one I can't even say what he
said in the one below recapitulate but
there's a couple what's the subject can
you say what the subject matter is how
he was
conceived this blog is wild we'll save
that one for the members portion of the
show I'm going to need this link as well
yeah immediately stabed oh my God we all
must know I don't know I don't think I
want to
know it gave you the gear symbols for
like a while yeah but now I've got the
whole thing at my disposal oh I have I
have it now too do you you just got to
hang there what year did you pick um I
actually just Googled read like I they
linked the article in press relas well
this went to an archived one so I don't
know this he did this October 24th
of gee I don't know if I can find the
year but yeah just recapitulate is the
name of it he was he he was committed to
this blog are you seeing it too because
I sent it to Hannah clir and slack just
to see if it would work I can see
recapitulate yeah is the inappropriate
word rhymed with it or is it just
basically slam poetry what am I reading
right to give me a hint I I did I did
the control fine for the the H to make
sure it was the right poem and can you
just post it in like I could try it yeah
just send it to me yeah see if get this
thing up take a look at what this guy
was talking about can you imagine his
staff right now his communication person
was like is there anything else and he's
like I can't say who who is to say or
maybe they all know maybe he's
constantly writing poetry in the office
this is how he like delivers memos to
people he's got a pseudonym on Reddit
maybe or cuz that's a good question
though is there another like if he
abandoned this one what what else is
there dude I bet he's got a Reddit he's
got a Reddit account an old one that he
a frequent ship poster unfortun CH as
well I would I mean 4chan's harder to
track but you can find his account on
Reddit and figure out what he was
posting yeah I bet he's got wild stuff
in there we should we shouldn't it it
shouldn't be so crazy a world that we're
actually sitting here seriously
speculating about that
too what I'm really what I'm really
interested in is what did he do to get
the machine to come after him like
this probably it's just the fact that he
had the fire alarm incident and stuff
and they thought maybe he' lose yeah you
probably just said H well we're not 100%
sure and you know we're going to be kind
of close in the house and the Senate
Anyway come the next election so you
know get lost yeah but he he'd have to
have resisted they go to him and say
you're not going to win re-election
because of what you did and he and he's
saying like no I can do it like you're
going to get roasted in the primary get
out they probably did it the soft way
first like saying look you know here's
the internal polls and you know we think
that it's best that you just you know
seek a different office run for mayor or
something like that and he probably said
no
and then they said okay yeah yeah but
they they'd say you know what happens
next you they may not have even
threatened him they might have
blindsided him that's true that's always
possible but I have to imagine like
unawares if he did something wrong and
the political machine said it's time for
you to bow out and he said no they need
to only say you wrote the blog you know
exactly what we're capable of yeah and
then he can be like
okay I guess I mean would it would it be
wouldn't it be funny if like Jamal buman
was like you can't scare me you're your
deep State conspiracies won't stop me
I'm going to run and do the right thing
and but like no one cares cuz he's kind
of a bad guy thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net